部活でスコーン作ったの
くれ
どぅもっ　はっ　しゃっ　しゅっ
はいというわけで皆さん最近
ゲームとかよくやられてますでしょうか
流行りのゲームとかあるんですけども
最近のゲームはもっぱら
サバイバルゲームだと思うんですよ
PUPG、荒野行動まぁ色々あると思うんですけでも
サバイバルゲームってそもそもどんなのかっていうと
なんかこの島とかに
なんか100人くらい人が集まって
そこで最後まで生き残った人が優勝みたいな
そうだから皆んなはねその生き残るために
人を殺めたり
時には家の中に身を隠れたり
誰かに向かって爆弾を投げたりと
こうとんでもない行動をするんですけども
そのゲームの中でめちゃくちゃ強い
アイテムがあるんですよ
それがこちら
もう見るからにそういう戦う
サバイバル感がある入れ物で
（はじめんなぜかむせる）
こんなにオシャレなんだ
あっなんか普通にいい感じ
開けましょう
うわぁ　おぅおぅおぅおぅ
なんかどうなってんだこれ
あのーｗ待って
ギリースーツってものがあるんですよ
あのー
…でございます
要するにゲーム内だとやっぱ
こう誰かに突然撃たれたり
普通の服着てたらバレやすいから
すぐ撃たれたりするんで
こういうですねあの草むらっぽい服を着て
草むらにカモフラージュして隠れるっていう
作戦がとても強いです
ちょっと着てみましょう
あおおおおー　おーなるほどなるほど
あっこういう、こういう、こっ、こういうことね
うわっスッゲーでも　うわぁ
はいというわけでちょっと自分だと
よくわかんないんですけど
結構隠れれそうな気がします
であのねゲームの中だと
本当に強いんすよギリースーツ
というわけで今日はちょっと
家の近くにね家の近くに
ちょっと草が生えてる所があるんですよ
でゲームの中だと全然バレないんですけど
ちょっと現実世界のギリースーツで
本当に隠れれるかどうか
僕ちょっとわかんないんで
えー今日は家の近くの草むらに
僕がこうやって隠れて
ギリースーツを着てたら本当に
カモフラージュしてバレないかどうかを
ちょっとみて行きたいと思います
では行こう
だ）行かないってもう
は）ではちょっと出ててや2人
だ）ははは
は）ちょっと出てて
は）あのー1人ずつ呼ぶんで
だ）うん
は）帰ってきてください
た）じゃもうここでいいっすかもう
は）ううん
は）早くｗ早くｗ
は）びっくりした　なになにｗ
た）あははｗｗｗ
はいでは早速完全にギリースーツに着替えました
中の服もバレないように黒にしたので
カモフラージュ的には完璧だと思います
では現場に向かいます
GO !
はいというわけで外にきました
ここら辺にちょっと植物があるので
ここら辺に隠れてみようと思います
ムズイな
場所を変更します
今一応家の近くにいるんですけども
ここら辺の木と同化できないかと思いまして
ここら辺に隠れてみようと思います
どうでしたか？
なんか正直自分だと隠れれてるかとか
よくわかんないんですよ
とりあえずもうすぐ一人ずつ家に帰って来るんで
家に入る時絶対ここ通るんですよ
その通る過程でそこら辺の植物に
カモフラージュした僕が
（最初のターゲット：だいちぃ）
は）わああああああ
だ）わっはっびっくりした
は）はははｗｗｗ　だ）びっくりした何⁉︎
カメラマン）着いたって
は）では隠れます
（続いてのターゲット：お友達）
友）すごーい　すごい超カコイイ
（4人で仲良く会話中）
最強や
（3人が話しながら戻ってきた模様）
（あれ？たなっちが消えているｗ）
（Success!）
は）けいすけー　ちょ、ちょっと外きてー
け）ウェイウェイ　はじめさーん？
け）ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
け）ｗｗｗ怖ｗいｗよｗｗ
け）やばいよ
け）やばいよ本当怖いよｗそれ
は）今気づいた？
け）わかんなかった
は）え？最初入った時も？
け）やば　ギリースーツや
け）ここはおかしいなと思ったけどわかんなかった
は）ははははは
け）ずっと居たすか？
は）ずっと居たｗｗｗ　け）ｗｗｗｗｗ
は）まじでｗｗｗ
け）わかんないわーーーｗｗｗｗｗ
【エンディング】最後にまだあるよ
や）おつかれっす　た）おつかれー
は）わっ‼︎‼︎‼︎  や）うわーーーーーーびっくりした
は）はははｗｗｗ